so there were many kids in this theater
that we're scratching their heads that a
lot of the comedy in this movie that
could be a good thing for you or a bad
thing
for me it was a good thing mr. Peabody
and Sherman is based off the old Rocky
and Bullwinkle cartoon segment from the
50s and 60s called Peabody's improbable
history it was the story of the smartest
being alive which just so happened to be
a dog named mr. Peabody who adopts a
young boy named Sherman he goes to court
about it he visits the president about
it he's able to legally adopt this son
in that cartoon and in this movie it's
basically the exact same thing he's the
smartest thing alive he never really got
along with the other dogs the dog pound
because he just wanted to read books he
didn't want to fetch and in this movie
they have something called the wayback
it's a time machine in which they go to
various times in history always in the
past never in the future and he uses it
to teach Sherman about history and when
Sherman meets this girl at school who
eventually convinces him to use the
wayback machine time and history gets
altered and they have to figure out a
way to go back to fix that no I was
looking forward to this movie because it
comes from the director of the Lion King
which is one of my favorite animated
films of all time it looked very funny
it looked like it had humour for adults
and kids and it does it has a lot of
humor for adults and kids in fact as I
said in my intro there were many times
this movie where kids did not get the
jokes and I can tell you that for sure
because I went to this movie with a
friend of mine he brought his two
daughters they're very young and even
though they enjoyed the movie for the
most part they were scratching their
heads at a lot of the jokes and that's a
good thing and a bad thing because kids
may not enjoy this movie but at the same
time I can see them being very
entertained by its overall action and
adventure esque feel and it's also good
because as a parent or as a guardian or
whoever you can take your kid home and
then explain the various historical
significance of these events and they
can actually learn something from it too
and it's also cool for an adult to go to
this movie and be able to laugh a lot
recognizing that a lot of these jokes
are actually made just for them and
while I enjoyed the movie overall I did
have a few problems for one I feel like
a lot of the characters in this movie
aren't as smart as the movies trying to
be the movie is trying to be very clever
and extremely smart with a lot of its
historical references and time jumping
and back and forth it gets a little
messy and a little convoluted sometimes
but the characters in the movie are so
cookie cutter stupid like the evil woman
who just wants to take
away from mr. Peabody and everything is
evil to her and then all the people at
the end of the movie who accept every
insanely crazy thing that's going on
around them as fact without questioning
it at all it has the syndrome lately
that I've been referring to as the
wildly accepted syndrome where you just
see insane events and you just oh okay I
get it that's how it is I believe it I
Frankenstein had that with the scientist
who accepted the existence of
Frankenstein and all these gargoyles and
everything in an instant this movie has
that too except this is a children's
family film so I'm able to buy that a
lot more those are a couple nitpicky
elements to it there are times in the
movie where it did feel like the
characters were really really annoying
but for the most part I had a lot of fun
with mr. Peabody and Sherman I thought
it was a clever film that was pretty
funny and I thought that the action was
handled really well one of my favorite
elements to this movie is definitely the
Trojan horse segment I think some of the
characters in that segment are very
funny one of the things I noticed was as
it goes back to different eras it
tributes like the most famous movie of
that type of thing that they are doing
like when they go back to Egyptian times
and they're in this room treasure
hunting and having to step on all these
things just correctly even though
Indiana Jones took place in like the 30s
they definitely tribute Indiana Jones
throughout that scene in the Trojan
horse segment there's a lot of 300
references for the most part I really
enjoy mr. Peabody and Sherman I think
it's a fun movie that kids can enjoy the
families can enjoy it's not a classic
like the directors Lion King but it's
still an enjoyable film that I think a
lot of people are going to have fun with
I'm going to give it a b-minus
so guys if you see the movie it already
opened in the United Kingdom people have
been asked me when I'm going to see it
but I live in America and I can't help
it it comes out later sometimes it comes
out this Friday let me know what you
guys think of it if you've seen it
already or when you do see it as always
guys thanks so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]